Salam alaikum welcome to the Deen show
chats and cars and I got our special
guest of the week sheikh mustafa omar
how are you [ __ ] I'm doing great how
about yourself
we got great topic this week we want to
talk about you know that we kind of you
know we always the morale goes up when
people end up coming to this beautiful
way of life it makes sense you know
pure monotheism purpose of life
everything's explained in the verbatim
word of God the Quran and and but
equally we get the morale kind of hits
you know elope when you sad to say some
people end up leaving Islam and it's
have you noticed this yeah unfortunately
this is it's becoming a little bit more
and more common and more and more open
there there are people who do that you
know usually it's people who don't
really have a solid foundation in Islam
but when they do leave it does feel bad
especially if it's someone close to you
someone that you you've known for a
while that's what I want to talk about
this week's episode one thing I
mentioned before was that now you can
have the
the best health club in town the best
reviews and at the end you end up
dropping your membership it doesn't
affect the health club does it in fact
it affects you or oh you're at the most
prestigious university and you end up
you know they got a long waiting list to
get in you dropout doesn't affect them
does it no no not at all you know the
religion of Islam is the same way I mean
there are there's some great people in
it you know and those who leave it
doesn't affect Islam because it's a lot
of great mnestheus religion what it is
you know so if you choose to drop out
you know it's not gonna affect it's not
gonna affect the law it's not going to
affect the religion of Islam the
religion will continue but it's
unfortunate and it's sad to see people
you know making that that unfortunate
step in their life but it shouldn't I
mean people drop out of school every day
you got so many high school dropouts
you know people drop out from many
things that if they would have just kept
with it because it requires some
discipline they would have achieved
something great so we shouldn't I mean
at the end get to I mean we do get a
little saddened but at the end it's only
the person that ends up hurting
themselves yeah yeah that's absolutely
true I mean sometimes we have like this
we have this perception that everything
needs to be perfect you know everyone
needs to be a perfect Muslim every
Muslim needs to go to the mud the mud
should be full everywhere but this is
not there that's not the reality of the
human nature that's just not the way
people are Allah is giving us freedom of
choice and when things like this
happened I actually look at it from this
perspective that this is proof that
Allah has given us that freedom of
choice right because if we don't see
that choice being manifested around us
we'd almost start doubting and saying
hey you know what if everyone's stuck in
the way they are where's that freedom
the freedom is there so we see it so in
a way actually it's somewhat of a
comfort even to see you know what Allah
promised that he
thus the choice is true and we shouldn't
we shouldn't lose too much sleep over it
because it will happen and it does
happen I want to cover a few things that
because there's a lot of you know just
like attorneys you know you can have the
witness and that witness is a credible
witness but the attorneys come on to
discredit could be a and in just an old
lady never committed a crime or anything
but now the witness's job
the attorneys job is to discredit her
and they end up playing that game and do
all sorts of corrupt things and we see
that happening today a bunch of
information I think you had you had
mentioned that though they'll throw a
thousand and one things out they're
hoping that just one will stick yeah so
how how and creating that doubt yep then
that doubt is created and they've
accomplished Shaitaan has accomplished
his goal whoever out there from the
haters they've set out to do and
accomplish what they set out to do so I
wanna I want to get into how can we
approach this when you when you have it
and I'll cover it I'll ask you for some
specifics yeah but in general how when
you when there's so much someone comes
and things okay Islam's the truth you
can't how can you refute it but then
they have a hundred and different
reputations for yeah for it what do you
say I mean there's two ways I mean the
first way is you know once you believe
and you have a good clear understanding
of your faith you don't give credence
and sit down and listen to every single
person is trying to confuse you you know
so you don't do that in any subject you
know if you can sit there if you're if
you're a medical doctor and someone
comes and says you know I got a
refutation to some medicine you're using
and you got 100 guys like this coming
your way and they got a hundred
different arguments you don't give all
of them an equal amount of time right so
that's one thing you know just don't go
to anti-islamic websites or anti-muslim
websites and sit there and read
everything and this is a major mistake a
lot of people make because what they
think is you know what if I'm a real
Muslim of my faith is very strong I
should be able to handle this so you
know what let me go and read up
everything that's out there to make sure
my faith is very strong well the thing
is sometimes people are very
overconfident about their own knowledge
and that's
the second thing is you need to have a
very strong foundation in your
understanding of Islam a foundation is
not just built up by one argument or two
arguments that you know were really
inspired you or convinced you or a few
lectures or a few speakers but having a
good solid Islamic education is very
very important before you even go and
start looking at these alternative
quote-unquote theories or attacks on
Islam that are out there so having a
strong foundation and not wasting your
time looking at every single anti Muslim
website or every single anti Islamic
argument that's out there is gonna help
protect you actually I don't think
that's a good idea I actually did that
in the beginning I did I did that in the
beginning because I also wanted to make
sure and I was someone who was sharing
and I wanted it I wouldn't I wanted to
make sure that this was the truth but I
always had reliance you know in the
beginning the whole concept of you know
tow he'd you know the simple the the the
pillars of Islam everything just made
sense and and I and and then I would
look into all of these other attacks
they were on there exactly what you were
saying not to do how I was doing it but
I but I knew there was answers for him I
was patient and and and the answers
would come you know I wouldn't as some
people don't use this as an escape go to
go and run and follow their desires and
hit the back door yeah but but
hamdulillah I got through that and came
out even stronger it's very similar to
what happened to me I used to do the
exact same thing and all these doubts
started cropping up and I used to go to
anti Muslim websites and and that's what
really motivated me to go abroad and
start studying Islam in detail so it
took me like you know five years six
years of studying in detail to start to
be able to answer all these questions
and every time more questions would pop
up I'm like now I gotta study more to
get these answers so it's a long journey
you know so those people who start
getting some doubts there are answers
out there but you got to put some effort
in there you can't just throw in the
towel you know when when they go and get
stuff when it starts to get a little bit
hot you're like I can't handle this
anymore
you know so we got to have that patience
and if you want to put in the effort put
in the effort and go study and get a
solid you know understanding of the
details and the principles and the
methodology in which you're supposed to
understand
texts of Islam now your show is gonna be
coming out soon we've actually I
interviewed you and you talked about
your journey
yeah from at from being Muslim leaving
Islam you are carrying Behati and hadith
books on your back and then you became
an atheist and then again life took a
turn a unique turn and you came back to
this LOM and now you're even stronger
you're actually an expert in this area
why don't you give us a couple examples
that comes to mind that someone has
brought up an argument someone who's
left Islam and they brought up an
argument and how would you explain that
yeah I mean one of the arguments that I
get people think that these these
scientific realities that are presented
in the Quran somehow contradict the
scientific realities of today no so
that's wait for the ambulance to pass
you
so these the scientific realities in the
Quran people think that somehow their
outdated and they contradict modern
scientific findings and it's ironic
because you know we talk about there's
there's there's scientific miracles in
the Quran and that's that's pretty solid
some of them are very very solid the
thing is when you look at verses in the
Quran like for example Allah says in the
Quran you know see how we spread the
earth the earth has been spread right
they say oh well if that bird has been
spread that means that the Quran
believed the Quran is presenting like
the earth is flat the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he actually believed
the earth was flat and you guys are
trying to like you know bend over
backwards and trying to reinterpret
these verses or something like that so
the problem with this the problem with
this is that people don't understand
that the Quran is speaking about things
in in nature and in reality from a human
beings perspective that's just the
reality of what's happening right and we
do this all the time right you look at
today you will go to a scientific
website or a scientific laboratory and
they're talking about sunrise and sunset
and as the Sun rises and does the Sun
actually set no it doesn't right
either's in reality there is no such
thing as sunrise and sunset but it's
from a human beings perspective so you
find the most reputable scientific
journals universities professors they
still talk about sunrise and sunset as
if it's a reality but they know that
it's from a human beings perspective why
do we still use those terms in this
enlightened age of technology and all of
that because it's effective it's
beneficial to us when we describe things
this way so if you go and you read in
the Quran and you say you know what
imagine is talking about sunset and all
of a sudden someone goes in there goes I
can't look at this book it's so
unscientific it's talking about the Sun
setting the Sun doesn't set we know that
now the Sun is actually there and the
earth is rotating okay that's great we
know that now but we still talk about a
Sun Rise in a sunset because we're
talking about it from a human beings
perspective so allah subhana wa ta'ala
he put these
in the quran in such a way so that when
describing things people can relate to
them and actually see it there's some
kind of benefit to them no one took them
literally right and if some if some
people did in history that's their
misunderstanding right give you an
example Allah talks about in the Quran a
verse where he talks about have we not
made the earth a resting place he's
talking about how the earth is spread
out how it's comfortable its relaxed
it's a resting place and then he says
didn't we make your sleep as a means of
rest for you so sleep is supposed to be
something where you know you can get
some rest and then he said didn't we
make the night as a garment now think
about that the word is Lee bass Lee bass
is a garment it's something that you
wear now does anyone actually think that
anyone ever historically think that the
night time when it comes it's like a
garment in the sky no no one would ever
think something like that right but
there are people who read that and
they're like all the the people of the
past they used to think that there was a
giant garment in the sky it's figurative
language to prove something it's it to
explain to you something that these
things were set up for you as a means of
being nama or a blessing for you right
so when people start taking things
literally that they're not supposed to
take literally and they take things
figuratively which they were supposed to
take literally that's when you start
getting confused about the Quran and
that's when problems start arising extra
and that can happen I we're gonna give
you some more as a wonderful example
we're doing chats and cars with Sheikh
Mustafa and we'll give them some more
examples when we come back here and
easily subscribe right now
you
back here on a Dean show and we're
talking about Muslims leaving Islam
and have you seen this become something
that's more of a comment read with the
whole new New Atheism and and have
people approached you you know they come
in your Imam at the Masjid if you have a
lot of Muslims coming up to you and have
you had a lot of experiences like these
are these unique isolated incidences I
mean I wouldn't say there's a lot but
there's there's more than people would
expect and I've had you know several
people actually come to me and tell me
that they have a lot of doubts about God
and this new atheism going on with Sam
Harris Richard Dawkins all these guys
they read about some of their theories
or some of their ideas in school and
then they start going and reading their
literature you know and usually it turns
out that one of their professors was
very very like an atheist or agnostic
missionary very passionate in the way
that they were talking against God and
against religion and just become more
and more common you find comedians
making fun of religion and then you know
they make fun of the idea of belief in
God and Muslims starts to become
affected by this type of propaganda as
well so I have seen many cases of it a
lot more than many people would think
and usually the problem is this is like
five or ten years in the making this
doesn't happen overnight all of a sudden
you know so people come when it's pretty
much like the worst case scenario like
when the when they've already they've
already been gone for like a few years
and then maybe they're a friend or the
parents or someone brings them in and
they're like okay now you know what
helped this guy in like 30 minutes and
it doesn't happen that way you know it
took five years to take place five years
of indoctrination and propaganda it's
gonna take a good amount of studying in
time to kind of undo this because when
the heart changes the mind changes need
to slowly start to undo some of that
damage that's there
give me another give us another example
a lot of times people will bring up
they'll try to bring up because there
are very unique things in the 'quran
that nobody knew of at that time and
many times we'll go ahead and highlight
these scientific you know signs in the
quran but then someone will come back
you know some of these people who have
left Islam and say no these aren't
scientific these were things known at
that time is there something that comes
to your mind a particular verse that
they bring up that you can go ahead and
elaborate on yeah I mean one of them is
about the story of a thorough quarantine
in the Quran there's a man by the name
of the little qarnain some people
confused him with being Alexander the
Great it's not that strong of a theory
in my opinion but when he's traveling it
says he reached the setting of the Sun
so they go oh he reached the setting of
the Sun and it was setting in a muddy
pool you know and they say oh well that
means that the Quran actually is
believing that the Sun sets every single
day you know in the in like a muddy pool
in the way that is being perceived and
all all the verse was actually trying to
say is he reached a very far portion of
the earth he was traveling you know due
west and when he reached that area he
saw the Sun setting and if you look at
the actual verse if you look at the
wording of the verse you look at the
Arabic language it's actually saying
that it appeared to him that way right
so that's all it's saying but what
people do is when they want to take
something very literally they're like no
no this is proof that the Quran actually
was trying to propagate an idea that the
Sun is something that actually goes down
into water or something like that and
the problem you know where this
originally arises is there's a lot of
propaganda against religion in general
right and there's this idea that
religion and science contradict each
other and there's been a conflict
between them now the problem is this was
the case with Christianity right when
they when they started going through
their scientific revolution
in there you know enlightenment and you
know their Renaissance and all of that
there was a problem with people the way
in which they were reading the Bible and
then you had all these scientists being
persecuted you don't have that same
history when it comes to the religion of
Islam in fact some of the greatest
scholars in Islamic history Muslim
scholars in terms of religious scholars
there were also scientists and there
were pious people they believed in God
they believed in the Quran and they
didn't have any issue there so the thing
is they're trying to project a religious
history onto Islam which doesn't
actually exist so what happens you we
live in this environment you know I grew
up in this environment where religion is
like looked down upon it's made fun it's
seen as a thing of the past and it's
looked like all these people who seem to
be practicing religion you know people
who aren't maybe probably very educated
in Islam or something like that these
people don't even know anything about
science they don't understand anything
about the world they don't understand
technology they don't know how to use
cell phones they get all impressed with
all these things that's the the reality
is you know that's not the case when it
comes to the Quran that's not the case
when it comes to Islam so if you come
with that negative mentality right it's
like imagine this you walk into Africa
and you think that Africa is just this
whole place just as backwards place no
one knows anything everyone is just
everyone is illiterate everyone is just
ignorant they're all just a bunch of
savages killing each other you won't
respect a single person in Africa you
know and when I went to Africa for the
fur I have family in South Africa when I
arrived there when I was on my way I was
actually scared I thought I'm gonna be
living in like some kind of tents and
I'm like what if a lion comes and
attacks me and what when I got there I'm
like hey this is a pretty modern city
but we have prejudices about many things
and that's the problem there's a
prejudice against religion there's a
prejudice that religion is backwards and
that means all religions are backwards
and the problem is Islam is an exception
to that rule even if even if the other
ones are right and obviously there are
some case to say that a lot of them are
and have been but Islam is one of the
exceptions to the rule and you can't
walk in and start trading it the same
way as every other religion that you've
encountered because it's not the same
give us one more example that comes to
mind another example that people use to
show the like you you'll hear for
instance
embryology yeah or many of these other
what we say scientific facts the
mountains a tactics as pets
embryology specifically I've heard that
someone say no was that gap
Galileo he actually was that the person
that was later on who was who was the
Perth day they'll they'll mention to say
these were common facts in a particular
person Aristotle you know Aristotle
understood some of this stuff yeah so
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he was copying from from so he had
access to like the Greek manuscripts or
something like that well first of all
that's not really possible for him to
have access to the Greek manuscripts and
for him to actually be studying
philosophy because if you look at his
life you'll realize that there's just
there's no way given given his
circumstances that he would have access
to that that's one thing the second
thing is if you actually look at the
books of Aristotle you look at you know
the things that they've written
Hippocrates on medicine and all of that
the amount of mistakes that they've
actually made in their descriptions are
numerous and you don't find these type
of mistakes in the Quran so that's one
thing second thing is they did not
describe in detail the way that the
Quran is describing in detail the number
of days and how the fetus actually goes
through several stages none of these
things have been described in any form
of detail so to make the claim is
actually it's very flimsy and people try
to try and bring a bunch of names and
all that they're like oh well this
person knew that and Aristotle knew that
and this guy knew that before but they
can't provide solid evidence showing
that this is exactly what it was like
so they just caught a bunch of names
they're like yeah they kind of had an
understanding of embryology they kind of
had a deeper understanding of science
well yeah maybe Aristotle was was more
knowledgeable and had a better
understanding of science than some of
the medieval European you know
philosophers or medical practitioners
during the you know the Catholic Church
times yeah that may have been the case
but it's not it's not the case that they
got all these theories are all these
things that are being talked about in
the Quran so there's a world of
difference people need to bring their
proof and that's why I lost two
processes in the Quran how to burhanakum
in quantum solving and that's what I
like to use just bring your proof if
you're truthful and whenever you ask
them to bring their proof it's kind of
like a roundabout kind of ditching okay
let me give you another example and they
try to change the topic on you you know
and that's the thing you just got to
call people out when they're making
claims they gotta bring their proof and
it's very important that they bring
something solid before we should even
you know listen to the rest of what they
have to say one more before we cut out
we're doing chants and cars and we're
talking about the fact that there are
some people who end up leaving the gym
some people end up dropping out of high
school college or the university they
harmed themselves if they would have
just been patient sought out the answers
with sincerity because if you're looking
for a loophole you're looking for for an
opening so you can get to the club or
maybe so you can you know not have to
live up to that responsibility because
belief in God belief in the crater now
is not just by talk I mean this action
you got it you have to it requires
responsibilities now right so now you
you you leave off believing in
the almighty and now you you don't have
to be waking up a flood you know more
it's it quite convenient right yeah
that's usually the first step I mean
people usually the first thing to go is
people stop they stop praying as much as
they used to and they started cutting
off their prayers and that's when you
start seeing that the doubts start going
higher and higher you know so like you
said you got to have sincerity and you
got to ask the right people you can't
just ask your friend you know that you
met in Sunday school and be like hey man
you know the answer to this and he's
like I don't know I always wondered
about the same things oh there must be
no answer then you know and that's it so
yeah you know we we hope that people
reconsider and we hope that people take
this very seriously all right let's do
one more tell me I've heard this where
someone say that the Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him he would
get different revelations conveniently
sent to him all right have you heard
this yeah I've heard this before you
know there are certain revelations that
talk about the Prophet peace be upon him
specifically in the Quran you know and
people make this as an argument they say
you know why why does why does God have
to come in and like you know intervene
and give the Prophet permission to do
something or approve something that he's
saying along those lines I've heard this
many times and and the problem is it's
it's not a fair argument you know the
reason why it's not fair it's it's not
even a strong argument is because first
of all if the Prophet wanted to do
something if he needed permission to do
something he didn't need it to be in the
Quran he could have just done it and no
one really would have called him out for
it anyways right because if you look how
dedicated the Muslims were if he did
something they wouldn't sit there and
you know criticize him and you know tell
him hey why are you doing something like
this one of the common things that I've
heard is there's a verse in the Quran
which talks about the Prophet peace be
upon him he he was shy to ask people who
used to sit in his house for a very long
time he was shy to ask them to leave and
that's you know something beautiful
about the messenger of allah you know i
mean he's
you don't really want us you have other
things to do you're a busy person
someone comes into your office and they
just want to spend time with you and you
know you you feel bad like asking them
you know can you leave you know I really
got some other stuff to do so he's being
shy so the response came in the Quran
it's chapter 33 verse 53 it talks about
how it talks about how basically allah
subhanho wa taala spoke on his behalf
and was telling people that you know
what the profit is being shy in asking
you to in dismissing you and asking you
to leave all right but Allah is not
shying from the truth so it means that
you guys need to just take it easy you
know don't spend so much time with The
Messenger of Allah you want to make an
appointment with him you know come and
spend like a little bit of time don't
sit there and say you know I need eight
hour appointment today and another eight
hour appointment tomorrow he's got other
things to do
so I've heard someone actually tell me
that you know what oh that's very
convenient that God had to come in and
intervene on the prophet's behalf just
for his own benefit or something like
that I mean this is a very poor argument
because what the verse is trying to
highlight is how Shai The Messenger of
Allah peace be upon him really is right
so the verse is coming down and talking
about how the Prophet is too shy to even
tell you this right so it's giving a
message to the people that you know what
don't harm him he's you know this is
something that you should be observing
good etiquette by not overburdening him
if someone comes along and makes a
statement says o the Prophet he put that
in there himself
right would he really let's just assume
that that argument had you know we were
even considering it seriously if that
was the case would he really put in
there that the Prophet is just too shy
and you know please try to leave him
alone they'd be much more forceful
language right it would make more sense
to actually go ahead and say you know
what stop bothering the Prophet don't
you guys you know fear Allah don't you
guys you know there could be much more
harshly if it was really annoying him
that much so the thing is that's that's
a flimsy argument that's one that's one
issue and
the second issue is that if you read
these revelations like some people come
and they say you know why did the
Prophet have more wives than four he had
more than four wives and all Muslims are
only allowed to have four wives but he's
in a special exception to the rule isn't
that just so convenient that he happened
to get the exception to the rule what we
don't realize is there's other
exceptions to the rule that were for the
Prophet which were not convenient for
him right
so for example him fasting more than one
day in a row this is not allowed for
anyone else he forbade the Muslims from
fasting two days in a row without
breaking the fast now for him it's an
exception to the rule he is allowed to
fast for two days in a row is that
convenient
in his favor no it's convenient the
other it's the opposite right it's
actually more difficult for him so he
was given certain exceptions to the rule
you're not as a Muslim you're not
allowed to do that so now did he did he
make the exception to make his own life
difficult no that contradicts the claim
that people say oh he made an exception
for himself just for his own benefit
this is an exception not for his own
benefit that he can fast two days in a
row if you look at chapter 80 of the
quran surah abasa says abbas owatta what
law says he frowned and he turned away
there's a story about a blind man who
came to the Prophet peace be upon him
asking for advice and the Prophet was
speaking to some very important notables
from the the honourable tribe of Quraysh
who are like the leaders of the
community he started convince them about
Islam trying to give them some special
attention and the man kept on bothering
him the blind man kept on asking him
questions while he was trying to talk to
these important political leaders so the
Prophet got a little bit annoyed and he
made like a frown thing and he kind of
turned away from the guys like I don't
want to talk to you right now and he got
criticized right so this revelation came
and criticized the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him in the Quran and every
single Muslim
reads that verse of the Quran when they
reciting the Quran and why would you put
that in there exactly I mean why would
you put that in there if it's actually
criticizing him so is that one of those
convenient revelations no so the thing
is when you actually go and you look at
all the verses that talk about the
Prophet you find that there are not just
exceptions to the rule that are
benefitting him there are exceptions to
the rule that are criticizing him there
are exceptions to the rule
like surah Muzammil chapter 73 it's
talking about it says yeah you had
Muslim men oh you who's kind of wrapped
up o me laila a la colina stand up for
most of the night except a little bit
mitzvah who I will post Minho kalila you
know stand for half the night or maybe a
little bit less so this is only for the
Prophet the Prophet is being told and
he's being ordered by the by Allah in
the Quran that he has to pray most of
the night I mean that's that's not a
requirement for the other Muslims but it
is for the Prophet now that's not
convenient right that's something I mean
try and pray try and pray half the night
all right the vast majority people
wouldn't be able to do it right but the
reality is the Prophet is being told to
do this as an exception to the rule
because he has special circumstances and
because he's a special person so when
you read when you zoom the camera out
you look at the whole life story of the
Prophet peace be upon him and you look
at everything that it says in the Quran
about the messenger of allah you realize
that this claim is a baseless claim
because you're going and you're looking
at a person saying oh look you made an
exception for himself he made an
exception for so okay that's a
hypothesis now zoom out and look at all
the other places where there was an
exception to the rule does your
hypothesis still stand no it gets thrown
out the window yeah we have two minutes
a few minutes left before we conclude I
mention attorneys they want to discredit
the witness in this case they want to
discredit the messenger
then bury the evidence overload people
with a bunch of false accusations one of
them hopefully will stick create some
doubt and now that's the test now you're
being tested are you going to go ahead
and follow your desires you're going to
be patient put your trust in in a law go
seek out the answers and you know are
you gonna follow your desires what
advice do you have for the person who's
you know you got these modern-day I call
them prophets the Sam Harris's and what
you had and you know you're overwhelming
your your your time listening to these
people in your in your you're giving up
your deen slowly people are at that
state you know and then it's no wonder
then they end up leaving you know that
connection with the almighty what advice
do you have for those people that are
out there that are on the verge now
right yeah yeah those people that are
out there you know I will tell you look
start reading start reading the opposite
because you're probably reading some of
these books you've been influenced by it
go read what the Islamic position is on
these issues make sure you have a good
level of self-discipline you keep on
practicing your Islam while you start
searching and when you're searching you
got to search properly you got to find
the right books you got to find the
right shares you know that you go to the
right scholars to ask them the questions
and just go and sit down with someone
who's knowledgeable about these subjects
and ask them say look this is the
problem that I have usually people
cannot describe in detail the problem
that they have because they don't
exactly know what the issue is going
they don't even have specific questions
usually they just know that they've been
they've been hit by all of these
different ideas and they don't know how
to deal with it
one of the books I would recommend I
strongly recommend a book called God
Islam and the skeptic mind the second
edition not the first edition first
edition is also good but the second
edition is better go and check what the
counter-arguments to these things are
and read these books carefully and you
will find that the answers are there but
you just haven't been searching for them
hard enough or you've just been going to
the wrong places
so keep asking Allah for help ask Allah
for guidance search in the right places
and put some proper effort into making
sure you read what the Islamic position
is on these issues beautiful don't come
to you you mentioned sincerity
connection with Allah keep asking but
don't come down love with an attitude
good point yeah yeah don't don't be
arrogant you know and that's what you
find with a lot of these people there's
a lot of these atheist is new atheists
they're very arrogant in their approach
and you don't want to do that don't
start making little you know YouTube
selfies about you know mocking this
Masjid or mocking that scholar or
mocking you know the Muslims I can't
believe they've they believe that they
believe in these dumb things or
something like that just just be humble
be sincere and just be as someone who's
searching for the truth yeah and you
know you ask Allah for help even if
you're struggling with that you're if
you're sincere Allah will guide you down
the right path have good o'clock have
good character don't lie don't steal
don't cheat don't make fun of people
don't mock other people and you'll find
that you get closer and closer to that
truth well thank you for being with us
on this episode of the Deen show and
chats and cars and keep the heart open
keep the heart open so I'll see you next
time until then peace be with you
something